[звучить бандура]
♪ Ой ти, пташко жовтобоко, ♪
♪ Не клади гнізда високо, ♪
♪ Клади його низько в ямці, ♪
♪ Ховай діток у зеленій травці. ♪
♪ Глянь, он там яструб над головою, ♪
♪ Літає, хоче ухопить. ♪
Для мене важлива Полтавщина.
Страшенно.
Усе життя живу ніби в Києві.
Але, коли мене
запитують, звідки я,
я завжди кажу,
що я з Пирятина.
Тому що в мене у свідомості
це місце, звідки...
Так було все моє життя.
І досі.
Тут жив один, світла пам’ять
йому, краєзнавець,
який написав величезну статтю в газеті «День»
про архітектуру, про модерн український,
про що ніхто ніде
ніколи не говорив.
Що по всій Полтавщині є дуже
багато шкіл, зроблених у цьому стилі.
Я тоді здивувалася,
бо я ж виросла тут
і ніколи не чула про це.
Стиль, який існував,
по-моєму, 30 років всього.
Він поєднує цей
європейський модерн,
за яким ми їздимо
дивитися у Відень, Клімт...
Це все, чим
ми захоплюємося.
І поєднувався з українською традицією,
із цього вийшов український
архітектурний модерн.
Потім його швиденько придавили,
щоби «хохли не дуже вирізнялися».
Я не хочу, щоб і далі про нас говорили
як про край, який нагодує,
про буряки, корови,
«мольоко», як у нас тут кажуть.
Відкрити цю сцену і побачити
там справжню Полтавщину —
з її неймовірними людьми,
які тут жили,
з тою культурою,
яка тут була.
Чорнухи.
Це ж звідси Сковорода пішов.
Світ ловив його і не спіймав,
ви в курсі?
[сміється]
Це одна з перших шкіл,
яку ми теж занесли в реєстр.
Подивіться на цю красу,
подивіться на цю башточку.
Вона абсолютно не схожа
на церковні споруди, правда ж?
А це якраз одна із тих веж,
яка вказувала,
що це храм просвіти, науки,
що це зовсім інший полюс.
На Полтавщині це особливий ареал.
Зразків українського архітектурного модерну
ніде немає стільки, скільки є тут.
Ми об’їздили всю Полтавщину
і наносили на карту ті знахідки.
Із них уже 35 ми зробили пам'ятками.
І перше, на що ми звертаємо увагу,
коли заїжджаємо, —
старовинні дерева,
що мають бути.
Отакі вони бувають поїджені
вже омелою тощо.
Але нам здається,
що саме там може бути наш об'єкт.
Тому що навколо цих шкіл
завжди висаджували сади, алеї.
От справді, це була не просто споруда,
де треба було зайти,
щось вивчити і піти додому.
Тут цьому надавали
особливого змісту.
Це оці старі дерева,
які тут росли.
Їм (можна порахувати
по кільцях) багато років.
А ось сюди вже можна
спокійненько-тихенько заходити,
як нібито вже тут
щось відбувається.
Тому що тут є виставка.
Ми їх об'їздили, всі ці школи.
Оце унікальна картинка.
Вона — руки Сластіона.
Він зобразив типову школу
із оцих всіх шкіл, яка вона має бути.
І це його рукою намальовано.
Тут, бачте, і масштаб вказаний.
І тут можна прочитати,
[що] це все намалював наш
Опанас Георгійович Сластіон.
Людина, яка була забута.
Досі я не можу зрозуміти, чому.
Одна компанія прекрасних
молодих людей:
Олена Пчілка, Леся Українка,
[Дмитро] Яворницький, Микола Лисенко.
І Сластіона чомусь із цього [переліку]
якось так тихенько викинули.
І ніде про нього
нічого не знаєш.
Тому ми почали досліджувати,
і досі ми до кінця не знаємо.
Але це була унікальна людина
з багатьма зацікавленостями.
Усі вони стосувалися
української культури.
Він займався минувшиною,
і вже в ті часи він писав про те,
як занепадає українська культура,
як усе зникає.
І він тоді ще рятував усе.
Часом я його сприймаю
як живу людину й досі.
А цей панський маєток
уже не впізнати.
Тут вигон тепер.
Але, очевидно, тут був сад.
Ну, одно слово, тут був театр.
Є старі фотографії, де люди йдуть
із театру в цих костюмах.
Вони грали дуже гарні п'єси.
А ось оце будинок,
де я проводила дитинство,
бо це будинок,
де народився мій батько.
Я сюди потім заскочу.
Гусики.
Боже, як я їх люблю,
цих гусиків!
Але це та школа,
яку ми врятували від мародерів,
бо її вже розпилювали там.
Один місцевий «панок» влаштував
там собі гараж для своїх траків.
А хороші речі – це ті, що...
Ось погріб зберігся теж цієї школи.
У цій школі останнє,
що тут було, — це ЛТП,
лікувально-профілактичний заклад,
де насильно лікували від алкогольної залежності.
Коли вивели звідси цей заклад,
вона [споруда] почала занепадати.
Вона прекрасна.
Подивіться, якої вона красивої форми.
Башти дві збереглися.
Це унікальний проєкт.
Усі школи, яких тут понад 50,
трохи відрізняються тим,
що в них різні візерунки на стінах.
В одних одна башта,
в інших — дві.
Перші школи були
дуже орнаментовані,
і були подвійні дахи,
двозаломні.
І такі люкарни — це такі віконця.
І вікна, погляньте, шестикутні.
Скрізь.
І двері.
Всередині у школі були
дерев'яні розсувні двері.
Також шестикутні.
Вони давали можливість із двох-трьох класів
зробити величезну залу для якихось подій.
Вона зроблена
з особливих матеріалів.
Це були прекрасна цегла, дуб.
Утеплення.
Була так зроблена пічна система,
що в цих класах було
абсолютно сухо й тепло.
Тут було дві толоки,
сюди з'їжджалися люди.
Сюди приїхали київські журналісти,
письменники і оце все прибирали.
Важливо цю школу врятувати,
тому що це один із найкрасивіших
зразків Сластіонового мистецтва.
Тут вчився мій батько,
і тому в мене є особистий
сентимент до цієї школи.
Ось отакий коридор.
Уявіть собі,
як тут діти мали почуватися.
Скільки вікон,
скільки світла!
Це були ворота в іншу цивілізацію.
Ці школи були призначені
не для багатіїв.
Вони була для всіх.
Усі діти, які сюди приходили,
були рівні.
Я впевнена, що це була би вільна нація,
якби вона й далі [була].
Ось оці стелі, коли ти
заходиш у таку школу.
Подивіться, скільки світла!
А з цих вікон було видно обрій.
Це, знову ж таки, було вибране одне
з найкрасивіших місць на цій території,
щоб поставити ось такий заклад.
Не маєток чийсь,
не щось таке [інше], а саме школу.
Чи вона потрібна місцевим людям?
Я ще не знаю.
Ми хочемо позакривати
всі діри на ньому [даху],
зафіксувати,
законсерувати її,
щоб стихія не руйнувала.
А сюди зараз приїдуть наші друзі.
І будемо щось робити.
[сміється]
Бродячі реставратори.
А що ви там робили?
[сміється]
Бродячі реставратори.
Добрий день!
Я тепер знаю, чого.
Ото з вами Вітя,
а він ніколи не знає, я так розумію, дороги.
[цілуються]
Ні, це я так поїхав, впевнений,
що знав, куди їхати.
— Так?
— Але пропустили поворот.
— А я врятував ситуацію.
— Ви врятували ситуацію?
— Добрий день! Радий вас бачити.
— Дякую, я теж.
— Я би точно не пропустив.
— Серйозно?
Діючих шкіл дуже небагато лишилось,
щоб саме школа.
У когось десь бібліотека є.
Їх, коли закривають,
то дуже мало хто пристосував.
І наше завдання — їх пристосувати.
Якби місцеві люди зрозуміли,
що це не просто те,
що валиться,
а що на цьому можна зробити
розвиток для краю.
Ми зараз так десь приїжджаємо.
А нам кажуть: «О, там по телевізору їх
учора показували, бо це ж Сластіон».
Люди, які жили біля нього,
не знали про це.
А тепер це стало відомим.
Толя. А ви хто?
Ви реставратор?
Чи ви хто?
[сміється]
Відчувати, щоб [тут] нічого
не нависало над пам'ятками.
Слухайте, ну ви даєте.
Я навіть...
Ау!
[сміється]
— Це все перепиляти.
— Толя, я не знала, що ви це вмієте.
[надворі працює електропилка]
Я за кордоном часто їжджу
по таких невеликих місцях, як оці.
Я їх «Пирятини» називаю.
У мене є Пирятин у Норвегії,
у Бельгії — скрізь Пирятин.
І там такі [є] невеличкі абсолютно
території, як вони це роблять.
Роблять дуже цікаві речі
у старих будинках,
тому ми хочемо і тут
зробити якийсь такий...
Я поки не знаю, що тут має бути.
Але щось таке, куди
будуть приїжджати.
Що завгодно можна робити.
Сюди можуть приїздити письменники
жити, писати про ось це все.
Для художників можуть
бути резиденції.
Пам’ятка, історія – це не те,
що вже відійшло і нікому не потрібне.
Ми ж усі маємо перервані біографії.
Зараз дуже багато різних фільмів
побудовано на амнезії,
як людина втратила пам'ять і ходить,
і намагається зрозуміти, хто вона.
Ми так усі живемо.
І коли ти з тієї амнезії вилазиш,
хай ти навіть про себе
взнаєш погану правду,
але ти вже переживеш
якийсь досвід пошуку себе.
Ти можеш змінитися.
Наші школи міняють свідомість.
Дуже багато людей, які приїжджають
на такі зустрічі, на такі толоки,
починають піднімати-піднімати,
згадувати дідів-прадідів,
вибудовувати оце своє
перерване минуле,
яке, звичайно, вже не вибудуєш.
Бо його із мертвих не піднімеш,
але можна інакше поставитися
до цього всього.
І жити інакше можна.
Дехто почав проводити саме
в цих спорудах свої святá села.
А це вже наштовхує на те,
що люди відбудовують свою пам'ять,
свою згадку про своє дитинство.
Про дитинство своїх батьків, про дідів.
Це крок.
Має бути ще багато таких кроків.
Але це міняє.
Ми дуже акцентуємо на малих, на дітях,
на ще не зіпсованих підлітках,
бо якщо їм це дати,
цей заряд,
то воно може трошки змінитися.
Вкладати в це –
це згадати, як тебе звати.
Ну, це частина мого життя просто і все.
Коли цим займаєшся – живеш
все ж таки у справжньому світі,
чуєш смак своєї справжньої біографії.
А головне – люди, яких зустрічаєш,
отакі, як оці всі,
з якими ми говоримо.
Не за копійку,
не за те, що їм десь там
пам'ятник поставлять.
А готові на це.
І ось це найбільше мотивує —
зустрічі з отакими людьми.
Отаке братство.
Свій до свого, знаєте?
Полтавці мають свій
темперамент особливий.
Про нього треба говорити таким,
яким він є насправді, а не оце...
Я хочу, щоби Полтавщина
позбулася совєцьких декорацій.
Стільки доклали зусиль,
щоб з неї зробити оцю
декоративну паляницю,
що треба докласти величезних зусиль,
щоби це було інакше.
Щоб сюди поверталися.
Я хочу, щоб вона просто була собою.
[сміється]